an election campaign shouldn't look like
this or sound like this not how Jeremy
Corbyn wants to be seen or how he sees
himself Labour's faith and race
manifesto launched overshadowed after
Britain's most senior Jewish leader said
anti-semitism was a new poison in labour
and the chief rabbi clear mister Colburn
is to blame
he says labour can no longer claim to be
the party of equality and anti racism he
says this election battle is that for
the soul of our nation if as the chief
rabbi says the overwhelming majority of
Jews are gripped with anxiety his words
about you being Prime Minister how can
the wider public vote Labour there is no
place whatsoever for anti-semitism in
our society our country or in my party
and there never will be
so long as I'm leader of the party and
since I became leader of the party the
party has adopted processes that didn't
exist before that has had a disciplinary
process that didn't exist before those
procedures not good enough for the chief
rabbi but they are good enough for this
candidate can the wider public in good
conscience now really vote for labour or
Beth I think Lord Dobbs very eloquently
highlighted today about the likes of him
and myself and others do not agree with
that analysis of the chief rabbi if the
Labour Party was anti-semitic or racist
in any way the likes of me would not be
a part of that movement mr. Corbyn speak
to you about it he must have felt quite
hard about it I suppose because that he
has prided himself from being an
anti-racism I think as a human being is
heard about yes
who wouldn't be if they're being
attacked in this way
mr. Corben grimacing on exit no doubt
keen to get away Christian and Muslim
leaders today acknowledge the anxiety
being felt by the Jewish community and
stood in solidarity with them British
Jews might only make up a small fraction
of the population but when it comes to
the continued criticism of jeremy
corbyn's handling of anti-semitism well
that definitely has cut through to the
wider public this is not just a problem
for British Jews this is a big problem
too for the Labour Party at the height
of the election campaign political
opponents quick to capitalize I do think
it is a very serious business when when
the Chief Rabbi speaks as as he does
I've never known anything anything like
it and clearly it's you know it is it is
a failure of leadership but questions to
answer to in his own party the Muslim
Council of Britain accusing the
Conservatives of denial dismissal and
deceit over the issue of Islamophobia
what we do in the Tory parties when
anybody is guilty of any kind of
prejudice or discrimination against
another group then they're out both
parties struggling to represent and
protect everyone in our society but the
chief rabbis intervention unprecedented
he suggests mr corbyn's unfit for high
office the critical question now is
whether the voters hear his message and
agree bathra B's Sky News Westminster